Londyn attack puts new focus on the use
of vehicles as deadly weapons video
captured the attackers SUV slamming into
best pedestrians on the Westminister
bridge near the British Parliament in
the past year vehicle tax in Ohio
Germany and France have killed and
injured dozens of people Don Dahler
shows us some of the countermeasures
he's on Wall Street in the heart of New
York's financial district Don good
morning good morning you'll find
barriers like these all over the
financial district and other areas they
are designed to keep cars away and
protect the pedestrians on the sidewalk
from the very kind of attacks like the
one that happened in London before he
was shot dead outside the British
Parliament building the London
terrorists plowed through dozens of
pedestrians with this SUV the simple but
deadly formula has been used before in
December 12 people died at a Christmas
market in Berlin in November 13 people
were injured by the driver of this Honda
Civic at Ohio State University and in
July the terrorists in this truck killed
86 people at a fireworks show in Nice
France even though we're safe on this
side Manuel Gomez is a former NYPD
sergeant and FBI agent you think we're
gonna be seeing more this kind of attack
I believe there will be copycats
statistically speaking Isis recruits
about 50 people a day internationally
the terror group has urged its followers
to use vehicles to attack large crowds
like those at the Macy's Thanksgiving
Day Parade in response police blocked
key intersections with more than 80
sanitation trucks these metal posts
called bollards can stop a truck going
50 miles an hour they around every new
u.s. embassy and federal government
building this is asymmetrical warfare
we're dealing with David Dickinson is a
senior vice president of Delta
scientific a company that makes them
twenty years ago or 30 years ago was
sort of this was very very unique and
now these are standard and necessity
Dickinson says his bollards are also
used by foreign governments corporations
hospitals even private individuals
bollards are commonplace in London but
they're not on the Westminster Bridge
where the driver Wynn
his terrorist rampage former acting
director of the CIA Michael Morell says
no matter the security measures a
determined attacker will find a way to
do damage the only way to stop these
kind of attacks is to defeat Isis in
Iraq and Syria bollards were originally
designed to keep car bombers away from
their target but now they're also
proving to be effective now the
terrorists are forgoing explosives and
using vehicles as weapons thanks Don